[Musique]
attends bouge parti me fait voir arrête
bouge pas
d'accord tu es braises élu
je les adore et adorable de me dire ça
parce qu'il est horrible
[Musique]
ou
est-ce que tu étais passé pourtant jouer
le remake the town je viendrai te
retrouver
le jour le plus bouleversant de ma vie
a été le jour où j'ai perdu tout le
monde
seul une infime partie de l'humanité a
survécu et s'est installé sous terre
depuis ce jour je n'ai jamais cessé de
rechercher mais
j'ai enfin réussi à la retrouver
est ce que c'est on n'en revient pas
est-ce que la colonie des mets loin à
environ 135km c'est dangereux c'est trop
loin tout ce qui bouge voudra tué de ma
part du court et tu te caches un hockey
les
caméras
as
tu es tout ça moi aussi t'es pas obligé
d'en parler car
tu peux venir avec tout ça
c'est un sabre de samouraï
tu dois toujours écouté ton instinct
compris
qu'est ce que je fais est sinon mastaing
aimerait
[Musique]
tu meurs achement encourageants comme
speech
il a fait tout ce chemin bonne vie c'est
ça gamin tu as déjà entendu l'expression
c'est perdu d'avancé mais tu m'entends
amertume cette guerre
peut-être qu'on retrouvera monde arabe
il faut moitié après bien reculer
[Musique]
c'est incroyable j'ai l'impression de
tom cruise
[Musique]